[Musique]
entre bruce veut permettre aux arts
martiaux chinois de se démocratiser
vous êtes en terre étrangère
monsieur
croyez moi si vous viviez ici vous
comprendriez dans le quartier chinois de
san francisco nos studios de goom fo ne
devrait accepter que les élèves chinois
comme je voulais déjà dit
vous ne pouvez pas comprendre mes tripes
man parce que ce pays
et le plus grand et le plus puissant du
monde
ça rentre dans vos textes oui c'est
clairement de la provocation
et c'est tout c'est ça votre couple
chinois que s'est il passé
melexis
face à l'injustice
je ne peux pas rien
aucune règle
on se passe car aucune photo
donc vous êtes enseignant aussi
j'enseigne kung fu chinois c'est de la
gymnastique
oui en quelque sorte il y aurait moyen
que disait moi on vienne à tafer de
décembre à tapas pêche n'était pas
invité basta pour être invité pour pécho
vous passez nasa coule plus que moi et
mes potes on est un peu galère je
voudrais savoir si tu serais partante
pour m'apprendre un mois et quelques
potes comme monde
pichot des gosses ouais t'inquiète on
est sauvés min ça sera dit oraux la
leçon et par personne
vous allez me dire chacun vautours ce
que vous avez d'origine à long terme
honneur voilà je suis chef de tout mais
si je suis comment tu me l'as en fait on
me démarquer j'ai mon amour de la danse
ça va être compliqué là ils portent de
supérettes et moche
la première chose que wayne neuf c'est
votre gueule c'est comme pour les
apparts elle met trois secondes avoue
choisir comment attirer l'attention des
meufs avec le regard je peux pas y
échapper était trop belle on voit quand
même quand t'es pas là bas voilà
peut-être qu'au nombre des marques et
vous allez me rends là de voir l'amour
c'est une du temple film en excuses et
l'amour pour vous c'est la merde on dire
ce que ça vaut le coup évidemment
et c'est moi confiance un tout petit peu
plus que le meilleur pour toi
nous on les voit encore comme des petits
bébés mais ils ont grandi mais j'ai pas
envie de palier une relation amoureuse
sérieuse à 15 ans
l'amour c'est très tôt pour faire tout
un
et c'est aussi 200 porcs
il pense être huit ans
elle vous enseignent comment pêcher
c'est ça tu es allé voir une fille de
joie
votre démo fils où j'ai pas de nouvelles
de lui depuis plusieurs semaines devant
l'arbre comme dans mon dieu quel bel
arbre bel20 était de l'arb rien corrigé
label arbre c'est noté l'impression de
faire ça ne fait jamais rien chez vous
et fabrice est en train de faire un avis
de recherche
[Musique]
les sommes à la recherche de ce jeune
homme
ça vous dit quelque chose mais c'est pas
du tout les gars à qui s'écrit saint leu
vous vous foutez moi
bhl armes c'est peut-être pour ça que
personne à appeler aux effets de cette
hausse et parce qu'elle va du bureau de
téléphone c'est pas eu quelqu'un qui
ressemblait pas à ça vous êtes un vrai
fardeau raspail s
tu fais comme si j'avais pu choisir
j'avais quoi comme solution aller au
procès que veux tu que je te dise
supposant que je sois l'un des patients
qu'est ce que tu me dis je te dit de
battre ouais
[Musique]
nous reconnaissons pas ce cancer
poursuit une fois médecin
est ce que c'est
ouais c'est lui c'est parfait maison
isolée loin de tours
mon frère à votre femme et votre vie
à toi de jouer et docks si mon frère y
passe j'te descend je pus ta fille je
bute ta femme et je peux tout [ __ ]
vieux on va s'en sortir
tu étais grand manitou dans le coin joue
pas au héros je vais commencer à ouvrir
bordés l'attend
on doit reprendre le contrôle
je viendrai vous chercher
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu vas faire tuer à tirer
sortez d'ici tout de suite
[Musique]
ah merde
je suis sûr tu es un vrai dur à cuire
[Musique]
je n'arrive pas à croire que ma fille
chérie blanche neige vient d'avoir 18
ans quand tu liras ces lignes mon sort
sera plus qu'incertain tout ce que
j'espère c'est que tu trouveras les cet
intrépide pour leur demander de l'aide
elle vient me régler mon une aventure
féerique par les créateurs de la reine
des neiges vaiana la légende du bout du
monde
des réponses faites des avis de
recherche posté les dans tous les
villages et trouver la cua excuse moi
mais comment tu t'appelles je m'appelle
rouge sous les rouges
[Musique]
c'est l'île des contes de fées des
accidents dus à des événements étranges
arrive tout le temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà la vraie mois blanche neige les
souliers rouges et les sept là qu'est ce
que tu veux exactement
j'ai eu envie d'écrire
ici tu seras la femme que tu as envie
d'ailleurs
elle a disparu je voulais savoir si vous
aviez eu de ses nouvelles non elle a
arrêté de venir c'est dommage d'ailleurs
dans la grande majorité des cas ces
personnes qui disparaissent choisissent
de rester introuvable le plus souvent
parce qu'elle appuie quelque chose
excusez moi je ne ferais pas être ici
non non sûrement pas
système de détention en australie est le
reflet de nos de nos mesures
d'accompagnement des l'immigration qui
nous permet de déterminer à la fois
l'identité des demandeurs d'asile et la
légitimité de leurs différentes demandes
de protection
vous commencez tous une nouvelle vie on
ne pouvait pas vous raccrocher au passé
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît il doit y avoir une
erreur je ne suis pas un tunnel des
endroits comme celui ci a partout
australie
pourquoi parce qu'on a des terroristes
pouvez vous confirmer qu'une citoyenne
australienne a illégalement étaient
détenus ici à barton
gens qu'on s'intéressait à toi ils
voudront sûrement savoir comment
quelqu'un qui leur semble a pu se faire
piéger dans un endroit pareil elle a
disparu depuis des semaines et vous
n'avez toujours aucune piste
et vous pensez que ce groupe a quelque
chose à voir avec la disparition de
votre soeur c'est dangereux pour moi de
dire qui est chiant c'est que plein de
gens meurent des familles s'en séparer
c'est de la seule chance qu'ils avaient
de pouvoir rester une famille et des
toitures les a privés un bête famille un
homme de confiance pourquoi vous ne
voyez pas ça en face de moi elle ne sait
pas ce qu'on est capable de faire
beaucoup pas mettre à couvert sur une
orbite qui est entrain convient dès lors
faire ici je suis désolé mais tant que
vous me direz pas qui vous êtes une
partie moi je vous dit il on fait
quelque chose dans les serres si j'étais
toi je m'enfuis ray si je te revois
encore une fois je te dirais
le monde entier doit savoir ce qu'on
fait subir ici on va bientôt leur dire
j'ai envie
tu peux que tu as encore rhodia cette
heure ci vivement que ça s'arrête celle
de pression ça fait beaucoup trop
longtemps que ça dure
si tu te reprends pas immédiatement main
tu finir en hp comme sa grand-mère babet
j'ai 34 ans je pas de boulot tu as voulu
devenir écrivain tu t'es planté savoir
faire un constat d'échec parfois site
avait du talent ça serait maintenant
pensez être une psychopathe cas sociaux
c'est sophistiqué audacieuse féline
féline
ça veut rien dire féline c'est juste une
façon polie de dire [ __ ] j'ai deux
choses c'est que tu réagisses fait
naître enfin comporter comme une adulte
ne prenez pas de venir d'elle maman
c'est comme pour les toques cl colo faut
que ça vienne de l'intérieur vraiment
que j'apprenne après conseiller de
féminité une femme doit savoir jouer de
ses atouts
enfin m'a pas du tout su rebondir matra
olympio rist me renaud sur adjani
j'invite le fauteuil rouge
il ya un truc je supporte pas que ce
sont les fautes d'orthographe c'est
exactement pareil fautes grammaticales
il faut sur le pluriel et festivals et
festive on sait jamais la saison des
tornades approche
mais il nous faut plus de chevaux pour
ce voyage long et difficile
ce mustang réussira toujours à nous
échapper
titulaire le plus rapide de tous les
muscles
oh
ce que je peux être ton nom
à
[Applaudissements]
ta générosité yakari et je te confie un
don c'est lé mal en quoi je peux parler
à tous les animaux et plus rigoureux
dans tout ça c'est qu'il parle castor au
travail si je marche comme ça le temps
que j'arrive au barrage qu'ils auront
terminé le travail qui tenait sa veux
dire quoi
c'est le nom que ma tribu messieurs
autant donner trop haut
[Musique]
et
allez
[Musique]
bonsoir
des substances j'étais illégalement dans
marelle soupçonne un début de pénurie au
cab rien que mon ex sénateur soit
responsable
le marié en a marre des gens c'est vrai
qu'en mars
y'a comme un poison qui qui émane du
marais j'avais déjà vu quelque chose
comme ça
il ya eu un tel équilibre entre la
lumière et les forces hockey